a student was given a piece of rope and
told to cut it into two equal pieces
keep one piece and pass the other piece
to the next student each student was to
repeat this process until every student
in the class had exactly one piece of
rope which of the following could be the
fraction of the original rope that one
of the students had
so the key realization here is that each
student is going to have the first one
is going to have half the rope and then
each student after that's going to have
half of that so all the possible
fractions are going to be powers of two
so one-half one-half times two one-half
times one-half is one-fourth one-half to
the third power is one-eighth one-eighth
one-half to the fourth power is
one-sixteenth and we could keep going
but lucky for us we already see the
choice 1 16.
now just to make that a little bit
clearer let's work it out a little bit
more just in case that seemed a little
bit too hand wavy for you so the first
student you have the whole rope cuts it
in half
and keeps half of it and hands that half
so they get to keep half and then hands
the remaining half to the next student
so the next student has the that half
but then has to cut it in half
and so that student is going to be able
to keep what i just circled one-fourth
and then that's half of a half which is
one-fourth and then hand that one-fourth
over to the next student the next
student is going to keep half of that
which i just circled which is one-eighth
and i think you get you you see the
general idea here this is one-half this
is one-fourth this is one-eighth
one-half to the first power one-half to
the second power one-half to the third
power and you could keep on going and of
course one half to the fourth power if
we go one more step
we go one more step so now you have one
eighth of a rope and the student cuts it
in half and keeps that keeps half of it
that's 1 16 right over there which is
what we actually picked